La volta al món a peu, dia 268.
Vinga, seguim caminant cap allà.
De moment, cap cotxe.
Tu, a gaudir aquestes hores.
Bé, m'he trobat aquí uns nois amb un vehicle molt particular
i em diuen, hola, hola, hello.
És un Fiat, eh?
Fiat Panda.
Atenció, perquè són
italians i suïssos.
Hola, els teus anomenes?
Hola, em dic Luca.
Alessandro.
Em van dir que feien un vehicle de suport
per a una creu que feia
alguna mena d'adventura amb la bicicleta, oi?
I quina és la viatge que heu fet fins ara?
De Suècia, el meu amic de bicicleta
és de Suècia, i intenta arribar
a l'Austràlia, a Sidney.
I jo m'agrada l'Itàlia,
a Suècia, a Milà.
I el meu objectiu és...
No ho sé, perquè
el meu primer objectiu era
Correme, a Cappadocia,
però ara soc al mig de Tadjikistan.
Pel que sé,
pots anar amb la bicicleta
fins a l'endemà d'Àsia,
però amb la bicicleta és més difícil.
Estàs seguint-la tot el camí o no?
Sí, estic intentant,
i després, obro una nova
fundació, intentant crossar
la frontera amb la Xina, amb el cotxe.
Sí, perquè és gairebé costat, crec.
Sí, he de fer la llicència de conduir
de la Xina, la platja de la Xina.
Per aquesta raó, no estic segur
si és possible per mi, amb el cotxe,
però, finger cross.
Alguns amics estan fent això
amb un camper van, i han dit
que han demanat 3.000 euros,
o alguna cosa així.
Sí, és el mateix per mi.
Sí, han demanat més o menys 2.000 euros,
i el més important...
El problema d'aquesta viada
i de crossar la Xina
és que has de mantenir
un guia de viada amb tu.
No pots conduir sol
al mig de la Xina.
No ho sabia.
És una àrea difícil,
al sud de la Mongòlia,
al nord de Tibet, etc.
Això a l'hivern serà bastant complicat.
Sí, és clar, però
amb el cotxe no és tan difícil.
Hotels, etc.
Sí, però també...
Però, com que aquesta
xarxa és trista o alguna cosa,
perquè la miro i veig que és molt antiga.
És com un motor especial o alguna cosa?
No, tot és original.
Vaig construir aquesta xarxa al meu jardí.
Vaig fer tot, des de l'enginy
fins a la pintura, i el meu...
Com diria? Perdó per l'anglès.
El meu objectiu és
demostrar que no necessites
un gran cotxe o un gran vehicle
per fer una gran aventura.
I tu pots prendre
la teva xicada xarxa i anar-hi.
Ok, doncs, moltes gràcies, Luca,
i bona sort.
Gràcies, bona sort a tu.
D'acord, a veure, m'han dit que puc
signar el cotxe. Vaig a deixar la meva
assignatura, que els de l'aixeta ja la coneixeu.
No és molt currada.
Mira, la repasso, vale?
Great.
Doncs aquest és un dels nois
als quals els estan
fent vehicle a suport.
El...
El Mathieu, el francès, també tenia
vehicle a suport.
A mi m'hauria anat molt bé, aquí a Tajikistan,
un vehicle a suport, especialment
el Pamir.
Bueno, tu, sense ajuda
serà més èpic, no? Serà més difícil
i després estaré
més orgullós de mi mateix, potser.
Molt bé, doncs ja hem arribat a la ciutat
més gran d'aquesta vall.
Mireu qui està aquí.
Eh...
Something wrong?
Ah, no, no,
just a checkpoint.
Ah, a checkpoint? Ah, ok, ok.
Maybe I shouldn't film then.
Doncs res, el checkpoint era un poli
que ni tan sols
ha parlat amb mi, perquè estava parlant amb un altre,
ha fet una foto cap al passaport i ja està.
Crec que els checkpoints al Pamir són diferents.
Has de presentar el permís al Pamir, que encara no hi estem.
Molt bé, doncs vaig a prendre
algo amb els italians,
a menjar algo, a pujar al vídeo,
carregar bateries, comprar al supermercat,
aquestes coses.
...
Bueno, aquí els nois del cotxe s'han demanat l'arròs
sense res, perquè també estan una mica malament
de la panxa.
You are already also a little
sick of the stomach, like me.
Jo no, jo m'he demanat tot.
I bueno, anem a fer-li unes preguntes als ciclistes.
Ok, so...
Of your route so far, what was
your favorite place?
I think
definitely
this crossing, sorry,
this crossing we just did
yesterday from... Tajikistan, so...
Ah, I mean, I mean,
I only biked in Tajikistan, so it's not...
Ah, ok, ok.
So Tayo maybe can answer better.
Cos'era la domanda?
El tuo posto preferito
del viaggio...
I have to reply in English? No.
Uh,
tough one, probably
probably
Tajikistan,
Georgia as well.
Yeah, those two.
I would say those two.
What about worst place?
Desert in Uzbekistan, please.
Yes, either desert
in Uzbekistan or in Kazakhstan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Terrible.
Best food?
The pizza I ate in Como
the day after I left home.
No, apart of that,
the plov in...
in the Seven Lake Valley in Tajikistan.
Ok. Worst food?
Like, what's the country
with the worst food so far?
A pasta I cooked
and it didn't cook and we were in Turkey.
The worst cuisine?
The worst cuisine...
The worst cuisine was in...
I agree. I would say...
Or Croatia.
Yeah, maybe I would say here
Uzbekistan, Uzbekistan, Uzbekistan,
Uzbekistan, Uzbekistan, Uzbekistan
was worse.
Best people?
Turkish.
Turkish, yeah.
And...
Maybe Albanian?
Albanian, maybe
Turkish...
Uzbek, Tajik...
Worst people?
Russians, but at the border,
not inside the land.
Only at the border.
What was the
best moment if you had to pick
one special moment of all the trip?
The Diarrhoea.
Maybe Eugeni, yes.
What is Eugeni?
Eugeni is like...
It's a god.
He was a truck driver
and he let us sleep in his
truck
during the night and it was a messy night
because of rain and wind.
And of course
he was from Belarus so we drank like
a whole bottle of vodka and we were completely
fucked up.
This was a good moment and
this morning I was pretty relaxed as well.
This morning was a good moment.
And finally, last question. Worst moment?
If you
don't count the food
poisoning, I would say
the desert in Uzbekistan.
It was too hot,
it was impossible to recover.
Toughest moment.
Gràcies.
La una. I porto...
Quatre quilòmetres.
M'he estat una bona estona dinant,
petant la xerrada amb els italians.
Estava pensant i crec que és la primera vegada
que, no que em trobo uns viatgers
perquè n'he trobat més,
però que paro una estona més,
faig dinar, tal...
No ho sé, potser ha passat una altra vegada,
no me'n recordo.
Tu, però molt bé, molt majos.
I tu, mira, sempre estic sol,
poder estar una estona
amb gent que té el mateix
objectiu que jo...
No m'importa fer menys quilòmetres
avui del que tenia previst per això, no?
El problema és que, clar,
avui volia fer
42 o 43
perquè així demà
acabava a un supermercat.
Com això avui no passarà,
crec que no en faré tants.
Hello. El que passarà
és que
no arribaré a aquest supermercat demà, llavors,
per tant, ara he anat a l'últim
supermercat que aniré en,
doncs això, 48 hores, no?
Més o menys.
I he hagut de carregar bastant menjar, menjar
bessura, però és que és el que hi ha,
és el que hi ha. M'havia resignat
que hauria de menjar el ramen, perquè
això sí que ho tenen, però no, en aquest
hi havia puré de patates, tu. Perfecte,
m'encanta el puré de patates per sopar.
I a més aquest, que ja us he dit alguna altra vegada,
que té les herbes ja,
té el sabor aquest que només li fot
aigua i ja està.
Molt bé, tu, molt bé.
Val? Doncs seguim,
ara em trobaré un altre cop els de la bicicleta
quan aconsegueixin
atrapar.
Bona nit.
Aquesta música que sol posar aquesta hora
de l'oest
enganxa molt
amb aquest lloc on
estic, eh? Sembla,
no he estat mai als Estats Units, però sembla això
una mica el canyó del Colorado, eh?
Tot sec, aquí molt angost,
aquest... Canyó com es diu
en català? Congost,
congost. Bé,
a un quilòmetre d'un teòric lloc d'acampada,
a veure què tal.
Al final he fet bastants
quilòmetres, eh? Després us ho dic.
Doncs aquí estem, on he
d'acampar, i hi ha una
superobra, amb un munt
de maquinària, no sé molt bé què diuen estar
fent aquí, perquè...
Un pont? És que clar, aquí a la que ve una
riuada, fuà, tot això...
No ho sé, no ho sé.
Bueno, allà en teoria
darrere hi ha el lloc d'acampada, que és
una caseta d'aquestes,
que està
coberta, anem a veure-la.
Doncs en teoria
era aquí, però veig que
els obrers han muntat com unes tauletes.
Ostres, i una altra tenda.
Bueno, a veure.
Segur que els hi comento, no passa res,
perquè hi ha espai
per posar la meva tenda, eh? Però bueno.
Poca tranquil·litat.
A veure.
Veig més obres allà.
Podria
intentar...
mirar aquí a l'esquerra, a veure si hi ha una cosa més...
privada.
No. Això és com un cul de sac.
A veure. Podria posar aquí, no?
Però és com... bastant
guarro. I encara si vingués un
camió encara... encara
m'atropellaria. Aquí dalt
potser podria mirar, però no. Crec que...
em resigno a posar-me
al lloc dels obrers.
Espero que...
que potser els hi trec el lloc de dormir.
Ai, de sopar. Una taula aquesta.
Bueno, els hi pregunto.
Al final sí.
Al final sí que he vingut a les casetes aquestes d'aquí dalt
i... i no hi ha ningú.
Pot ser que sigui
un lloc on dormen ells.
Bueno, en qualsevol cas
els hi diré mola.
Veig unes fustes aquí.
No veig un.
Veig aire acondicionat.
A veure.
Sí, hi ha com unes lliteres, però no hi ha res a dintre.
Bueno.
Bastant polsagós,
però què farem, tu.
Ho tenim. Vinga.
Són les set i deu.
Mira, ara ve un camió.
Ara ve un camió.
Bueno, suposo que aniré a portar
les tigres d'allà.
Ja ho planto, tu. Ja està.
Doncs, quan has sigut avui? 44 km
i 900 i pico de desnivell positiu.
He parlat amb
els cinc italians i
una persona més, que és que ja
ja no he volgut gravar més
perquè cada cop que he de traduir
i subtitular alguna cosa d'un altre idioma
al català, és bastanta feina.
Però he parlat amb un home
que parlava francès.
Més o menys hem pogut comunicar.
Un tagíc, eh? Un tagíc que havia estudiat a la universitat
i vivia a Alemanya.
I això.
De cafè res i m'he gastat...
És que els italians m'han convidat a dinar.
Moltes gràcies. Grazie.
Sí, sí.
I llavors m'he gastat crec que
uns 15 euros perquè he fet la compra aquesta
més o menys gran.
I res, ha sigut
un dia molt polsagós, com sempre.
I una acampada molt polsagosa, eh?
No m'agrada acampar a un lloc així.
He intentat ficar tota l'intra
perquè no s'ompli de pols, però...
És que no em molesta
que hagin de s'omplir de pols. És la pols de l'ambient.
Que m'entra als pulmons, saps? És horrible.
És horrible. És horrible.
Però bueno, a part d'això ha sigut un molt bon dia.
Especialment comparat amb ahir
que estava baix d'energia. Avui
l'haver dormit bé, haver menjat bé
l'arròs, haver
parlat amb aquesta gent, doncs m'ha omplert.
I avui ha sigut un bon dia
i ha estat molt bé, molt bé.
Demà serà tot pujada.
Demà
serà dur.
I no entrem al Pamir pel que es veu.
Jo pensava que aquest pas que farem demà
és el pas que entra al Pamir, però no.
Això serà d'aquí uns dies.
Però bueno, igualment, mira, és que se'n cau el moc
pel tema de la pols.
Bueno, demà us explico el tema aquest.
Igualment serà molt guapo. 3.200 metres, crec.
Fins demà.